regardez-moi cette bécane absolument
incroyable alors ça je pense que vous
connaissez pas ce système c'est une
marque qui s'appelle verge verge en
français c'est la PS ultra alors elle
est juste magnifique on se parle ici
d'une moto totalement électrique 1 0 à
100 quoi en 2 secondes et demi bref le
truc est fou mais surtout moi ce qui
m'interpelle c'est tout ce système là
que vous avez en fait vous avez toute
une partie fixe là qui permet d'avoir
cette partie ronde vide au centre et
votre roue va venir tourner autour de ça
je la trouve juste magnifique en noir
mat comme ça elle est dingue elle est
pas vue rouler il y a quelques petites
vidéos ici on voit je trouve ça
absolument incroyable je suis motard je
vois ça tombe amoureux clairement là je
suis amoureux d'ailleurs je pense que
vous en pensez est-ce que vous aussi
vous êtes amoureux amoureuse de cette
moto marquez de moi dans les
commentaires